bier auf Wein das lass sein Wein auf
Bier das rate ich dir den Spruch gingen
sie alle aber jetzt wurde
wissenschaftlich untersucht ob da
wirklich was Truhe ist weil tatsächlich
war dass eine Studie gegeben wird
mehrere Jahre gedauert und an dieser
Studie da hätte der Baumberger auch gern
teilgenommen
ich mache das alles im Dienste
Wissenschaft und da haben sie vor allem
junge Probanden Hamster gehabt und da
haben viel für die junge Menschen die
Studie abgebrochen weil ich eine einfach
zu viel Alkohol war weil die haben da
auf Ohren Sitz und die zwei Liter Bier
und einen Liter Wein trinken müssen und
da bestätigt sie wieder das was
irgendwie sagt die junge Leute
das hätte doch bei uns eine geben dass
wir die Studie abgebrochen hätten ja
immer gesagt